all right this is super interesting you
guys may remember we've been covering
this incredible double standard this
incredible hypocrisy where Fox News
hosts and many in right wing media have
been slamming the Joe Biden vaccine
mandate protocol requirement in which uh
large employers with more than 100
employees have to either get their
employees vaccinated get proof that
their employees are vaccinated or they
have to test their unvaccinated
employees once a week now Fox News has
implemented a much stricter protocol
where you either need to be vaccinated
or test daily and you're required to
wear a mask when working on location in
certain areas so the fox protocol the
fox requirement the fox guidelines call
it whatever you want it is stricter
stricter than the ones outlined by Joe
Biden another Fox host was confronted
about this this is really interesting
this is Pete hegseth who's a big
anti-biden guy big bomb thrower and he
was interviewed by mediaites
editor-in-chief Aiden Laughlin and when
he was confronted with this double
standard where hexath is regularly
railing on the Biden protocol but fox
says his employer's protocol is stricter
he first wasn't really sure what to say
then he resorted to attacking mediaite
which might not surprise you let's take
a look at this very instructive there
was a vaccine or test requirement at the
Patriot Awards which is very similar to
the policy at Fox News do you have an
issue with Fox News having a policy like
that which is effectively the same as
Biden's vaccine mandate for big
businesses
uh I uh
you know you're not mandated to get the
vaccine because you can get a test right
now remember
it's the same thing with Joe Biden
you're not mandated to get the vaccine
because you can get a test I'm not in
charge of it uh I don't make the calls
but either you
you have the option to get a test so
you're not it's not actually a complete
vaccine mandate and that's fine I mean
so it's not my call so I'm grateful for
the people that provide us this
opportunity and
and um the show went off without a hitch
right but it's just that you know Joe
Biden's vaccine mandate for big
businesses has been the subject of
criticism and that's even less stringent
than the one at Fox News right it
requires weekly testing as opposed to
daily testing so I'm curious as to why
you have an issue with the Joe Biden
vaccine mandate right but no problem
with the one at Fox News beautiful
foreign
well answer the question say for example
well
uh I'm doing it to get clicks
or it's our editorial position and it's
totally hypocritical or like what he
wants you to say is answer the question
Pete
I mean
ultimately uh
companies have prerogatives what the
government shouldn't be doing is telling
them what to do
the government shouldn't be telling them
what to do every company has its own
policies and I'm beyond grateful for the
opportunity to work with Fox News
Channel and it does things that no other
organization does including your
organization mediaite so now he just
goes into attacking the the interviewer
it's part of the trash heap of left-wing
media that you know does the same thing
everyone else does that's why we're
number one I mean I I can't even imagine
what the clicks are on your site is it
like 15 people a day like only
journalists in New York City they click
on your that click 16. good they're the
only people that read mediaites exclude
you'll read read the Fox News Channel so
you guys want to nitpick and do your
thing it's cool but it's funny to say
it's nitpicking to point out that Fox
News has been waging a propaganda war
against Biden's vaccine mandate while
having a stricter mandate for its own
employees Pete hegseth calls that
nitpicking uh I I could not be more
grateful for the Fox News okay so there
it is so he eventually comes across
something that sounds kind of like an
explanation which is Hey listen I'm fine
with private companies doing what they
think is best but they shouldn't be told
by the government that that's what they
had to do but in in getting to that
explanation
he first has to attack media to get
there and insult them and say you guys
only get 15 clicks and this is this is
actually very common remember when
Tucker Carlson was confronted with the
same thing his reaction was just as
bizarre okay so I I have a question here
about Fox News
um yeah
you said Fox News has no vaccine mandate
but according to Newsweek the company
requires unvaccinated employees to
submit to daily covet testing which is
stricter than Biden's mandate which
calls for weekly testing right
businesses that employ more than 100
people is Fox News denies the civil
liberties uh of its employees by being
stricter than President Biden fair
question I don't know I mean you should
probably ask Newsweek it sounds like
they've got a pretty precise handle on
what's Happening
hey if it's wrong let me know if I'm
wrong
it's it's completely wrong as I noted
the other night
um I'm not you know so what is the
policy
to speak for the company
um on this because I don't run the
company and I'm not you know I'm just
gonna no that's very disingenuous Tucker
could just speak to his experience with
the policy as an employee he doesn't
have to speak on it as an employer it's
very disingenuous company
um my personal preference is that Fox
News would you know make a statement
about what its policies are but I think
like a lot of companies
um you know they're hesitant to do that
because like why would you even want to
get involved in that conversation here's
the bottom line
you know there are a lot of infectious
diseases out there a lot and a lot with
much higher mortality rates than covet
19. and you know there's there's HIV so
then as a reminder he goes into kind of
comparing and equating
covid vaccination and covid to HIV which
is of course uh an insane analogy given
that HIV is sexually transmitted you
can't sneeze on someone and give them
HIV there's no vaccine for HIV I mean
every time that they are actually
confronted with this
it's a fair question every time
they know that they're stuck in an
inconsistent position and they either
get angry and turn to insults or they do
what about ISM so nice job there by
mediaites Aiden McLaughlin and Pete
hegseth looking kind of like a doofus I
must say one of our sponsors is kamikoto
making elegant high-end beautiful
Japanese steel kitchen knives using
traditional techniques from Honshu Japan
I've been a big fan of Japanese kitchen
knives for a long time they have some
great advantages when you look closely
at a kamikoto knife you see the quality
of the iron work they only use Japanese
steel every knife comes in a perfect
heavy duty Ash wood box makes storage
really easy it looks great in your
kitchen or drawer the balance of the
knives is just amazing I've been using
them for everything every knife comes
with a lifetime guarantee on the their
website you can see the complete list of
chefs at Michelin star restaurants who
use kamikota and through this
partnership they're doing with us
kamikoto is giving you 50 off on top of
their other special offers just go to
kamikodo.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for fifty dollars off the link is
down below